it's called the modesty rule and
basically they were saying that your
which which I find funny because it's a
school issued soon soon it's not like
[ __ ] was like I'm wearing this from home
like they gave it to her to do the meet
and then make punished you for it
I would be so mad but you brought it up
and then you ended up telling everybody
about right yeah go ahead and tell your
pardon story so I head coach of a
different program in town and our meet
ended and I got back to my phone and it
had just blown up with texts and emails
to say this swimmer got disqualified at
another meet in town she's in a team
suit approved by the school district and
I said that's not okay if we don't do
something really extreme about this then
it's never gonna end because any girl
with a behind like you know like mine
like I'm just saying any girl with like
a bootie like that's gonna ride when
you're being athletic and you're moving
around it's gonna move it does the same
thing with men yeah like I is there a
modesty rule for men in this sport
because it just seems placed on women
than on men it's Randy takes her shirt
off and everybody's talking about it but
guys can do it it's nothing I mean take
your shirt off and shut your what a New
Orleans yeah you are covered you are
covered like this I think so my thing is
I mean right and you're telling me
that's alright but like her cheek kind
of hot suck I mean you can't help it
it's there I'm so mad today
I know I was so what was your what we
heard that they kind of are deciding to
maybe overturn this modesty rule for the
women right like by the end of the year
so it between the blog post going viral
and them having that on their desk and
sitting down to make a choice about it
it took them less than 24 hours to
return her victory probably really stunk
for you because you worked really hard
and you just didn't know why but god
that's it's amazing that they did turn
it around that quickly usually it is
fast usually it's a lot longer so he
changed it is suspended pending review
oh come on
technically what did that for beating
the rule in the rule book states that
you got to wear a suit that covers the
important parts now the rule kind of
sets everybody up to fail because it
doesn't specify how much of the
important parts needs to be covered they
should probably look at that anyway but
looking at that at your three you're
actually a creep if you're looking I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this